white women's lives matter white women's  lives matter yeah you know what I say to  that all women's lives matter  true no but right now we're focusing on  one woman's life or one group of women's  lives guess what you're saying is true  but we just want to put some focus on  the ones you're just saying it as a  reaction I I personally just don't see  color and I want to focus on all women  yeah but I feel you're doing to  undermine what we're trying to do yeah  no I don't think I am can you at least  acknowledge what's happening to white  women I acknowledge what's happening to  all women  exactly do you know hey hey guys I get  it I get why you do this yeah that's fun  it's a fun position to take all women's  lives matter what you're a Nazi you're  nice yeah you're not yeah wow  [Laughter]